why is it necessary to have an orgasm
why would selection have favored having
an orgasm sometimes and not others why
does it happen so infrequently measure
several variables related to the
masculinity and dominance of their
partner including taking photos of the
guys and measuring objectively how male
typical the face was how masculine it
was or how feminine it was having those
faces rated by unfamiliar people we
found that those things correlated
pretty well and that women whose
Partners were more masculine that those
women took less time to have an orgasm
during sex and more likely to have an
orgasm
David I want to talk about the female
orgasm I feel like that's what
everybody's come to hear us talk about
female orgasm a massive mystery you've
done some really really interesting work
on it
why does the female orgasm exist what's
the what's the function of it
that's a great question
um and I would say uh it's about 10 of
the research that we do in my lab but
about 90 of the interviews that I do are
about on that topic and you know I guess
I should start by saying we don't know
um but if I had to sort of put my money
on a hypothesis it would be that it
functions in mate choice and
um
and you know whether it that could be in
a couple of ways I mean it could be that
it functions to
um
to choose mates of high genetic quality
that will make females Offspring
healthier and um and more fit themselves
or it could be that it functions to
choose
um long-term investing Partners or it
could be some of both I mean there's
some evidence that
um that orgasm increases the probability
of conception
um and so you know it makes sense then
that I mean it could be for either
function it you know if if mate if
orgasm functions to choose males of high
genetic quality then it would make a
special sense especially since that
um it would be more likely
um to increase the probability of
fertilization but um but you know
there's also lots of evidence that when
women feel closer to their partners and
have an emotional connection that orgasm
is more likely as well so
um I could talk about some of the
evidence that you know sort of bears on
this but
um
I guess
well maybe I maybe I'll stop there or
maybe I I could I could actually maybe
I'll say how I got into this
um which was I always sort of you know
appreciated it as an interesting
intellectual question and I understood
that
um some evolutionary biologists
uh
you know thought that it was likely an
adaptation and it makes sense that you
know it might be it's something that uh
is so intimately connected to
reproductive behaviors that it seems
unlikely to be selectively neutral you
know to have been
um irrelevant to our ancestors
reproductive success
um but then you know it's something that
males are much more likely to have an
orgasm when they have sex and some women
have never had an orgasm and there's not
some kind of Smoking Gun evidence for
its function that there are plenty of
other evolutionary biologists who say no
it's it's not an adaptation it's just a
sort of a happy coincidence and that
it's really a byproduct of selection
favoring orgasm in males that in the
same way that males have nipples because
of selection on females female mammals
some female mammals they have nipples
that selection on males to have orgasms
has produced a similar trait so and and
uh in females and so you know I
appreciated that question
and then uh I guess about
15 years ago or so I was asked to review
a book on the topic
um and I thought for it for a journal
for archives of sexual behavior and I
thought okay a great chance for me to
get into the literature a little bit
read a book that reviews the literature
and uh and also have a publication I was
a postdoc at the time and I you know the
more Publications the better I thought
at the time and
um I the book sort of took a strong uh
ostensibly it was
um sort of more neutral but I came away
you you anyone reading the book comes
away thinking that the author really
supports the byproduct hypothesis that
orgasm is not functional and human
females and I came away from the book
feeling that the author was more likely
to be wrong
um than when I started the book you know
that it just seemed to me that
you know you could pick away at any bit
of evidence and say well it's an
imperfect study this doesn't show for
sure but every bit seems to support the
hypothesis that that women's orgasm
functions in choosing mates um and that
it's unlikely to be simply a byproduct
that you know it should be reduced for
example but byproducts like men are
bigger but their nipples are smaller
because when when selection doesn't
favor a trait
um and it favors it in one sex and not
in the other that it tends to be a
vestigial or rudimentary in the sex
where it's not an adaptation and if you
think about the sort of phenomenology of
female orgasm if anything it's bigger
than it is in males less frequent but
that could be it makes complete sense if
it's
um functions in choosiness I had Carol
hooven on the show a little while ago
and she was explaining about what
happens when people take testosterone
and transition from female to male and
then some people detransition and go
back and she spoke about sexual desire
and sex drive and stuff like that but
she also spoke about spoke about
subjective orgasm quality and spoke
about the difference between
uh natal women as she calls them and the
sort of full body uh much longer lasting
sort of sort of warm feeling than taking
testosterone transitioning to being a
male or a man at least not transitioning
to being a male transitioning to being a
man and then having a more sort of
localized higher Peak less duration and
then de-transitioning back and going oh
my God I've seen both sides of the the
fence here that is fascinating and I
would love to talk to those people I've
you know I've sort of um
also have some anecdotal evidence from
just you know sort of uh yeah talking to
people and and
One account was that um this was also a
this is second hand I got this that
um so friend of a friend
um transitioned
um you know a female to male and started
taking testosterone and said before I
started taking testosterone I could
masturbate after I started taking it I
had to it was just like a necessity
so anyway yeah that's interesting
um thinking about this sort of you know
physiology underlying some some sex
differences
um and I'm sure that some of some of it
is sort of some of the differences in
sexual desire response and so on are
sort of Direct effects of sex hormones
acting on on the brain including
patterns of gene expression in the brain
and then some of it of course is also uh
the effects of those sex hormones on
Anatomy right I mean you know penises
and clitorises are aroused in different
ways and you know
so yeah okay so previously I think the
when I first started getting into
evolutionary psychology the first
explanation I had Beyond it just being a
byproduct of some Vestige of it being a
the orgasm being a byproduct of the man
was for bonding was the fact that
there's this flood of hormones that gets
released after that how how much
contribution do you think there is with
regards to the oxytocin and the feel
good and the closeness and stuff that
females have after sex yeah I I go ahead
after orgasm after sex right right yeah
so that is an interesting I mean we
really don't know a whole lot about
um this hormone that's released uh in
the brain from sexual arousal and also
especially after orgasm but oxytocin
does in in experimental you know
laboratory mammals it does have an
effect on sort of bonding pair bonding
behaviors and and socially monogamous
rodents and and there's some evidence in
people too although it's just harder to
do a well-designed experiment and people
um but
um but I I think that it it must have
some kind of an effect like that to make
uh women feel more emotionally close to
their partner and also there have been a
couple of studies that have
um treated women with oxytocin and
looked at
um what happens to a a sperm-like fluid
a semen-like fluid it was the same
viscosity as semen and radio labeled and
um so some women were happy to
participate in a study like this but it
was treating women with oxytocin and
looking at what happens to this um
this semen-like fluid after oxytocin
treatment the answer was that it's
always brought into the
um
it's always brought into the uterus but
the question is does it go up into a
fallopian tube because that's where
fertilization takes place right when the
egg is released from one side from one
ovary then
there are generally sperm waiting there
uh if if fertilization is going to
happen then there'll be sperm waiting
there
um sort of embedded with their little
heads embedded in the epithelium there
and then and then they can you know one
one of them can fertilize the egg so you
have to get sperm there and sperm swim
but a little bit you know it's just like
they have a little they're tiny and they
can't get very far on their own the way
that they're they move up toward the egg
is through peristaltic muscular
contractions of the female reproductive
tract is the female tract that's moving
them upward and these uh this fluid was
moved toward the in into an oviduct and
the closer that the women in the study
got to ovulation the bigger their
um follicle was that so closer to
bursting and releasing an egg the more
transport you had just into the oviduct
where an egg was going to be released
and this was just after oxytocin
treatment so that's kind of to me that's
kind of strong evidence that if you if
you do an experiment and you treat some
women with the hormone that's released
especially after orgasm and its effect
is to move sperm or a sperm-like fluid
toward and up the oviduct where an egg
is going to be released and the closer
you are to ovulation the more fertile
the more of that transport just goes up
into that oviduct I mean that suggests
that orgasm also has that function
because why else would oxytocin play
this role you know this this hormone
that's released um during sexual arousal
but especially after orgasm the the
price that people pay for science those
women right that would happy to have a
semen-like substance put inside of them
then be treated with oxytocin right then
have it tracked to see whether the Cilia
waving it along and getting it into the
right fallopian tube dear God
um but
how do we not know if that's the case
how do we not know that female orgasm is
not just a mediator between the act of
Sex and the release of oxytocin
um
how do we know it's not a mediator
that's not just the only function for it
all it is is just like a gatekeeper that
says oxytocin is what's to go it's got
nothing really to do with anything else
at all it is it's just we're releasing
oxytocin that's going to improve
fertility
oh it could be but then the question is
um I mean at a sort of I think that's
the hypothesis is that it plays that
role but then the question is
um why why do
why is it necessary
um
to have an orgasm and why does it happen
sometimes you know like in other words
why would selection have favored having
an orgasm sometimes and not others why
why does it happen so infrequently
um you know if if selection just said
look the natural selection that has said
look
um it's some you know what's favored by
selection is having more offspring than
you would expect
have or an orgasm every time with sex
because that increases your chances of
of
fertilization that increases the number
of Offspring but if it was more like
well but having being pregnant all the
time is not a good good idea if the
mates are of differing quality then you
know select ones that are more investing
more caring more loving more have better
genes for your Offspring whatever then
it makes sense to have this mechanism
that increases the odds of fertilization
be dependent upon those characteristics
you know be dependent upon the uh the
quality of a male and we know for sure
that it's not necessary like women
plenty of women you know have kids that
have never had an orgasm in their life
um so I think if anything it's just
um increases the odds and given that
it's something that doesn't happen all
the time and there's also some some
evidence that measures of male mate
quality increase you know affect the
probability of women having an orgasm
um it seems like
it seems like it has that function to me
but
um I want more evidence you know I can
imagine a study where
like so I gave you circumstantial
evidence that orgasm increases the odds
of conception but what would be really
great is to do a study like we have some
idea of the Fertile window
um because people have
participated in studies where they
recorded when they had sex with their
partner and then um later found out when
they when they got pregnant and then you
can sort of model that and say okay so
these are the days that are fertile the
day of ovulation and it looks like the
five days before if women had sex during
those days they had a non-zero chance of
of conception so you can sort of say
these are the probabilities and
conceptions on different days of the
cycle you could do a study like that
um but also have participants record
whether they had an orgasm with their
partner and then see how that influences
the sort of daily conception risk
um and that that would be strong
evidence that orgasm increases the odds
of of conception but that kind of
research I would love to do it someday
I've just got so many you know whatever
irons in the fire I haven't sort of
taken steps so what I do is whenever I
talk to somebody about this they say
this would be a good study somebody
should do it I don't know if I'm going
to do it but so what you would be able
to do there is split test uh sex from
orgasm and non-orgasm to see just how
much of a fertility tool boost yeah it
is it is to do that okay so talk to me
about the relationship between dominant
men and orgasm success
well uh so we published one study uh
about 10 years ago where we
um had women in their heterosexual women
and their male Partners
um participated as couples and they but
they answered all the questions
separately about you know sexual
response and that sort of thing
um and we made sure that you know they
were they understood when they were
going in that they were not going to
find out the answers that their that
their partner provided
um and we found that women whose
Partners who rated their part we sort of
measured several variables related to
the masculinity and dominance of their
partner including taking facial photos
of the guys and measuring objectively
how male typical the face was how
masculine it was or how feminine it was
having those faces rated by unfamiliar
people having women rate their Partners
on sort of you know dominance and
masculinity and we found that those
things correlated pretty well and that
women whose Partners were more masculine
that those women
um
uh I had an earlier orgasm or more you
sort of it took less time to to have an
orgasm during sex and
um and it's more likely to have an
orgasm and so we suggest you know we
thought well there's a lot of literature
that suggests that traits that require
high levels of sex hormones to produce
um that those are indicators of
underlying genetic quality and so our
prediction is well if
female orgasm functions in part to
recruit good genes for your Offspring
then women should more easily orgasm and
have earlier you know earlier timed
orgasms with
um with putative good genes males in
this case sort of more masculine and
dominant and that's what we found
um you know I'm happy with the study but
it's I'd like more data you know what
one study doesn't prove anything would
it not be possible for men to overshoot
dominance I've been I've had a bunch of
conversations about ancestral leadership
and stuff like that and it seems like
the the Tyrant dominant male actually
ends up being killed pretty quickly
because people don't like that in a
small tribe of 150 people so did you
find dominance topping out at all is
there a way to overshoot on dominance
that is a great question and
um
I think I don't recall looking at it
Although our sample size you know the so
when you're starting to look at both
linear and curvilinear effects then um
you'd like uh sort of the more effects
you look at the bigger sample you'd like
and I and I I just
now I'm wondering if we still have those
data I don't think we looked at that but
that's a great possibility and I think
you're absolutely right about that and
in fact
um I think that that's something that
characterizes other primates too but
might be especially true in humans that
um we've sort of
uh so
in our ancestors our males probably
competed via contest competition by you
know threats of aggression and actual
physical aggression and one mating
opportunities that way but we engage in
a lot less a lot less frequent um
fighting than say our closest living
relative chimpanzees I mean human males
are more likely whether they're boys or
men more likely to fight and get you
know get it engaged in some kind of
physical altercations
um than females but it's about one
percent as frequent as it is in
chimpanzees and I think a lot of that
has to do with exactly what you said
that
um maybe around
two million years ago one and a half
million years ago and around Homo
erectus that we
um got really good at killing including
each other and the Predators we we
became sort of hyper Predators around
that time probably
um there's evidence of sort of uh
increased carnivore increased brain size
changes and and shoulder uh structure
that would suggest throwing
um and that once we became very deadly
um then it became important not to get
out of hand with your uh you know
because you can easily escalate a small
disagreement to one that becomes lethal
yeah despots can be can be killed by
anybody
um and so it's more important you know
and then of course there's also
coalitional aggression in humans and in
chimpanzees but it you know Warfare is
something that it seems to have happened
throughout human evolution and that
requires some sort of
um you know uh group cooperation and
competition against other groups as well
so anyway I I'm sure that you're right
about that that
um that you know there's a lot of
emphasis in human groups on Prestige
which is freely conferred social status
that you you get Social Status by
conferring benefits to the group
um and um and you know you have to be
careful with the dominance with coerced
um status because
we're we're deadly dude I tell you what
would be an awesome study to be able to
do
to look at the uh local Ecology of the
situation that the particular tribe is
in if the tribe was in a time of more
stress I.E potentially there are
um external tribes that are going to war
with them there is more male aggression
between tribes that is a time it seems
like anthropologically where it is
useful for a more dominant leader rather
than a prestigious leader people want
the person that's going to just get [ __ ]
done the more Psychopathic traits maybe
a little bit better I wonder if that
would be reflected in female orgasm rate
and mate choice
great idea yeah it's a completely simple
superbly simple study to do obviously
um yeah I can imagine doing it a big it
would be huge right big cross-cultural
study
um hopefully getting some data from sort
of non-western societies as well
how cool would that be to work out
whether female mate Choice uh Wayne sort
of swings between Prestige and dominance
uh preference based on what's going on
situationally I think you could do a
study like that
um both with sort of stated preferences
you know you could ask people what
they're after but also
um yeah looking at at orgasm as a
potential mate Choice mechanism as well
I think that would be yeah that'd be a
pretty cool study
um I I've you know we're in my lab we've
recently done some cross-cultural work
and it is if you want to get a good
representative you know set of societies
it's a ton of work but it I think it's
well worth it I I think mostly what
people are interested in human evolution
want to know is sort of uh about humans
broadly not American undergraduates or
British undergraduates or something and
so it's nice to sort of look at how
some of these mating mate Choice mate
competition patterns are similar across
societies how some sex differences are
similar and how they how they change as
well what are some of the
socio-ecological variables that that
predict those differences and can you
can you predict those things based on
you know evolutionary theory like you're
doing now so yeah I love it okay so you
mentioned there about contest
competition and this was the first time
that I ever got introduced to the idea
of it was reading your work and when we
think about sexual selection a lot of
the time we consider sort of the
ornaments of sexual selection right sort
of the peacock's tale type thing but
when it comes to humans there are a
bunch of and also other animals as well
but when it comes to humans it seems
like there is a huge number of other
types of competition that are going on
so what what do you think have been the
primary mechanisms of sexual selection
when it comes to humans okay
um so right so when people who study
sexual selection which is the kind of
natural selection that favors traits
that when mates
um when they think about that they they
sort of tend to categorize into
different modes or mechanisms right ways
that you could win mates so there's
contest competition which favors uh you
know
size strength aggression weapons it's
it's the use of force or threat of force
to to win mating opportunities there's a
mate Choice which favors you know uh
ornaments and sexual displays but
there's sperm competition sometimes uh
two males mate with the same fertile
female and then the male who produces
more sperm or more viable sperm or more
motile sperm is more likely to fertilize
um and sexual coercion is another one
that happens across many animal species
that you know males can use force not
just against each other but also against
potential mates to win mating
opportunities and if I had to sort of
rank
um mechanisms of sexual selection
operating on human males over recent
evolutionary history let's say in the
past you know a couple hundred thousand
years I'd say probably contest
competition then mate choice
and then uh I'm not sure between
coercion and sperm competition but I but
between those first two
um contest competition and mate Choice
um when I when I started studying this
stuff in grad school the literature
everything I was reading pretty much
talked about how male traits like if we
if we talked about say beards or deep
voices or facial masculine or anything
like that it would have sort of talked
about that trait as if it were a sexual
ornament for attracting females and
I started doing research on The Voice
um I can remember
sitting on a bus in Pittsburgh thinking
about what am I going to do for my for
my dissertation I wanted to have
one of at least two characteristics
either it has some obvious sort of
utility and helping Humanity like it has
some medical relevance or something like
that or and or it opens up sort of a new
area of research that hasn't kind of
been done yet and it just I think I was
I remember sort of having that debate
with myself about you know what what
should my dissertation be and what
characteristics should it have and I
thought back to
um doing some holiday shopping at a mall
in Pittsburgh and hearing two guys
behind me who seem to be competing to
talk in a lower voice pitch with one
another
um you know like this like what is going
on and I turned around and noticed oh
there was a cute young woman near near
them and they were probably you know
trying to show off like ah yeah and so
then I'm sitting on the bus thinking
about this and I thought you know voice
has to be a sexually selected trait
right I mean it's like the deep voices
of human males
um were uh
you know a little bit bigger than
females but our voice our voices are way
lower than you'd predict like human
males are about seven or eight percent
taller so they're vocal folds then
should be about seven or eight percent
longer but they're sixty percent longer
they're like 10 times as as long as
you'd predict
um based on the size difference and
voice pitch you know it's it's
half the fundamental frequencies like an
octave lower in males it drops at
puberty when when sexually selected
traits tend to appear they don't sort of
you know antlers don't grow in a deer
until they can do some
they have some function they're not
competing for mates when they're when
they're juveniles but when they achieve
sexual maturity then they start
competing and then the those costly
traits can sort of pay pay for
themselves in terms of winning mating
opportunities and so anyway I just
thought thought about voice and I
thought yeah that's got to be sexually
selected and I kind of went into that
thinking
based on the literature that I've been
reading it must be about female Choice
like it's got to be a sexual ornament to
attract females and once I started doing
research on it I I discovered that sure
women prefer
um deep voices a little bit lower than
average but the effect of the same pitch
manipulation when I manipulated sort of
the masculinity of a voice the effect of
the same manipulation on other men's
perceptions of a guy's fighting ability
was 15 times as big as the biggest
effect that it had on women's
preferences that women kind of cared a
bit but it was just had this huge effect
on perceptions of dominance and I
thought
you know form follows function like we
can sort of infer ancestral selection
pressures by looking at the traits those
selection pressures design and men's
voices look like they're much better
designed for intimidating other guys
than they do at attracting women and
then I started thinking about other
traits in the in the literature on them
and I you know every study sometimes
it's kind of swept under the rug in the
paper but um it studies that look at say
the manipulating the same trait like
facial hair on women's preferences and
appearance of dominance it always has a
much bigger positive effect on
perception of dominance
then attraction to women and so that
that got me thinking about sort of me
the design of men's phenotypes the the
male phenotypes and I just uh
kept finding out sort of more studies
and more evidence that men's phenotypes
really looked like they were designed
primarily to either win fights or
intimidate their same-sex competitors
more than to attract females we we don't
look like sort of peacocks with sexual
ornaments as much as we look like a
typical mammal and really a typical
um eight I mean if you look at all of
our closest relatives you know males
fight each other for mates and they
don't really have any clear sexual
ornaments but they have large bodies and
aggression and you know
what are some of the other uh
differences what are some of the other
ways that males have developed in a a
unique pattern that gets explained by
this contact contest competition uh okay
let me think here well we there are many
traits and I mean if we go back
to say traits that we should that have
probably been around for a couple of
tens of millions of years that we share
with you know all the other great apes
um
large body size
um you know males human males have about
say 35 percent more fat free Mass
um and about 60 more muscle mass
um and their skeletons indicate of a
primate that's about maybe
um 45 to 50 percent larger than than
females
um and uh aggression you know I
mentioned that there's
less frequent um aggression in human
males than there is among say
chimpanzees our closest relatives but
it's equally lethal and so that means
that you know if human males fight each
other
uh one percent of the time then it's a
hundred times as is lethal
um among humans
um weapons so that the typical weapon in
in primates is long canine teeth and
um and you see that even in socially and
monogamous like Gibbons and Siamese they
have long canines because it's useful to
have a weapon to use against
con specific same-sex competitors but
Predators as well and then
um we lost our long canine teeth and
that you see that in the first hominins
um so the first bipedal Apes about seven
million years ago that there's a
reduction in canine size
um with the evolution of bipedalism and
adaptations of the hand that look like
it's good for gripping something so
um there's a ton of sort of speculation
and theorizing about this among
anthropologists but to me Darwin was
probably right that we you know evolved
uh bipedalism to
to use tools and um and that once we did
that we our Primary Weapons became not
canine teeth but you know rocks and wood
or whatever for
millions of years until we developed
more sophisticated um Weaponry well why
would I tried to bite someone why why
have to get your head so close if you
can just put a rock in your hand and
smash them over the face that's right
yeah like we we don't have the typical
primate weapons but we have way way
better ones yeah have you read a bill of
on hipple's work on this uh oh I I'm
sure that I have no it came out about
three or four years ago it's really
really great he just he says the same
thing He suggests that it seems like a
really really cool Insight I got from
that was that if you give toddlers a
playground and on the playground there's
a couple of appropriately sized rocks
right there is something in them that
drives them to go over and just pick it
up and practice throwing
that's like it's so [ __ ] interesting
yeah that is so there's another right um
now there are big differences in
throwing and
um so there's about a one and a half
standard deviation male advantage in
targeting
um that seems to exist even if you
control for differences in practice
um
there is a one and a half standard
deviation in accuracy yeah targeting
accuracy of throwing even if you have
the same level of training between men
and women so the the research that's
been done on it has tried to control for
for practice and actually
um Melissa Hines
it seems to be driven in part by
Androgen by exposure to Androgen like
testosterone
um Melissa Hines showed that uh women
with congenital adrenal hyperplasia
which is a condition where the adrenal
glands produce elevated androgens before
they're born that they had sort of
targeting accuracy that was intermediate
between unaffected females and and males
now who knows exactly whether that's
effects of sex hormones acting directly
on the developing brain and the regions
that are involved in targeting or
whether it's more involved in like what
you like to do and spend your time on
um and whether you like to engage
whether you want to go and pick up a
rock yeah yeah yeah well I mean I the
first place I'm going to here is that uh
proponents for the WNBA uh probably
slightly unhappy to find out that there
is no way that you can level the playing
field between the two groups it'll be
very difficult to level the playing
field because there are certain things
that men have a predisposition to be
better at than women do and it seems
like throwing is one of those I've never
watched women's baseball but if they use
the same size
um whatever it's called area the area
that the throw is actually permitted in
right Strike Zone Strike Zone I would
guess that the number of balls
that are thrown in the women's MLB will
be greater than the number that are
thrown in the men's MLB yeah well so the
I don't know if there's there's softball
I mean women tend to play softball which
is a little bit different it's underhand
pitching dude I watched that it's
[ __ ] vicious it is so far and they're
closer as well apparently the pitches
the actual time that you have on the
pitches is way shorter because they
throw pretty much not far off as quick
and it's super short from the mound to
the batter yes so it's so vicious
um
yeah and I I don't know too as much
about that but I but for sure you know
if if somebody has gone through male
puberty then that gives them certain
physical advantages in in physical
competition that are difficult to erase
and the and the evidence suggests that
um
that you can't completely you know that
even like say removing testosterone you
know there's some changes that have
already happened that are
um but what did I want to say about
throwing that the the there's also a
even larger uh sex difference in
throwing velocity and that is present
very early on so I mentioned a one and a
half standard deviation sex difference
there's a one and a half standard
deviation and throwing velocity by age
three and by age 12 it's three and a
half standard deviations which is one of
the biggest uh you know when you think
about
the sex difference in height is about
two standard deviations
um and it's easy to see that males on
average are taller of course and if you
look at the WNBA you can see there are
lots of tall women
um but but there's a you know pretty big
sex difference in height but it's
nowhere near the size of the sex
difference in throwing velocity here's
the thing that no one's speaking about
when it comes to the discussion about
men and women in each of the sports and
the trends leagues and stuff like that
no one is talking about almost everybody
is using velocity
right everyone is talking about the
ability to generate power nobody is
talking about the predisposition to be
more accurate or more precise with
particular types of movements
that's really interesting it is and yeah
I mean given that some Studies have
tried to control for both report like
participants own reported practice with
throwing activities but also
um and one study I'm thinking of tried
to select an activity throwing targeting
behaviors that nobody had much
experience with like underhand throwing
of a
um of a ping pong ball or something I
don't remember what it was exactly but
it was something that like if you're
playing typical throwing Sports you
wouldn't have practiced this anyway
um to to try to control for differences
and experience
um
so that suggests that some of the sex
difference isn't due to just
um you know what you like to spend your
time doing
um but either way
those sex differences also are ones that
are consistent with an evolutionary
history of sort of males targeting each
other
um but it's also the case like I
mentioned that you know somewhere
it seems like for the first say four
million years or so of hominin evolution
we were typical
um ape
um
omnivores where we ate a lot of plants
and um had some meat in our diet chimps
hunt
um you know red called this monkey
sometimes they eat meat too they're just
not not as much they're mostly frugivors
eat fruit you know and our early hominin
bipudal small brain like chimp-sized
brand ancestors for the first several
million years probably we're not eating
a ton of meat and then maybe
became better scavengers uh three and a
half million years ago by but by the
evolution of our own genus homo around
two million years to one and a half
million years ago we got really good at
hunting and we know that and so it's not
clear how much of the sex difference in
throwing velocity and targeting has to
do with male male competition and
targeting each other versus targeting
prey because we also know when you look
at modern hunter-gatherers that there's
a big sex difference in subsistence
strategy that males hunt more and
females forage more and that like if one
if only one sex hunts in this group it's
males if one sex hunts bigger game it's
males I mean it just I'm just describing
something I'm not saying how it should
be yeah but it makes sense it probably
was ancestral as well yeah exactly it
makes complete sense about why the men
would have this uh overpowered throwing
ability if it was mostly them that were
having to go out and throw stuff at
other animals so I mean this is the
interesting thing about the the male
male aggression and how how much that's
driven sexual dimorphism and the traits
that we see in men and how they're
different in women how do you separate
out the traits that men have that have
been developed to be effective at
whatever dominance and aggression toward
other men rather than just straight up
survival or uh ornaments or like
Wilderness uh yeah Wilderness survival
yeah um
you know you can't in many cases and the
reality is that for any trait of any
organism there are often many selection
pressures operating on it simultaneously
and sometimes those pressures work in
opposition like
um for stature for height and human
males
um
probably there's sexual selection
favoring a taller height than it than is
the average and there's ecological
selection or survival selection favoring
a shorter height you know because it's
costlier to produce this uh you have to
have more resources to produce and
maintain that kind of phenotype and so
those are you know sort of body size is
one of those traits that that probably
sort of ordinary natural selection or
ecological selection and sexual
selection are working in opposition
um but any trait has
um you know sort of multiple selection
pressures operating at the same time and
so that's true of sort of typical
masculine characteristics in human males
that there's almost certainly been
female mate Choice male contests and
ecological selection at a minimum
operating on it and so it can be really
hard to say how much of trait X is
because of male contest but if you you
know do careful experiments and you look
across societies and see similar
patterns and say wow
um you know this trait looks like it
functions much more efficiently at
function X than it does y or Z then that
that suggests that you know that's been
a stronger selection pressure and and
when you look at human male traits it's
just that they look like they function
better and the experiments that have
been done and and also sort of
correlations with in sort of more
um uh naturalistic type studies
correlations with outcomes as well it
just looks like male traits function
better
um and for contest competition and and
you know many of these things existed
way before
there was a specialized hunting in
humans like you know our
all of our closest living relatives have
male male competition and fighting and
stuff so large body size muscularity
aggression
those things have existed probably for
tens of millions of years in our lineage
way before there was anything like you
know specialized hunting so yeah I heard
that the brow Ridge The increased brow
Ridge that men have would maybe be one
of these particular traits that as soon
as you have hands especially amongst men
bigger hands that can be balled up into
fists that you can punch each other in
the face with it is adaptive for you to
have basically an extra little bit of
armor that runs that runs across here is
that something you've come across yeah
um it is and
I I know that I have suggested it in a
paper in 2010 and I don't remember if I
was plagiarizing somebody I hope not and
I know that a guy Dave carrier
um has has published more on it and sort
of talked about the evolution of of
hominin skulls in that in that light
um we so human males have a more
prominent
um supraoccipital Taurus is the name for
this
um uh uh super orbital Taurus is that it
yeah super orbital to a hot simple what
let me tell you um and uh and and more
robust mandible and
um it makes sense that those would
provide some protection against
fractures of the of the face and the in
the mandible
um they're fairly gracile they're much
less robust than they than were on our
ancestors you know
um a million two million years ago
um but but still the sex difference yeah
I mean it makes sense to me that uh a
slightly larger brow Ridge could protect
eyes from punches or hits from other
things too you know a rock or a club or
something like that
um and same thing with a jaw I mean
that's like
you know young males get way more jaw
fractures than anybody else and it's you
it's the most commonly report other than
car accidents which are evolutionarily
novel
um across studies the most common cause
is
um you know uh hit with a blunt fist or
blunt object you know so that's how they
get these despite having a thicker
mandible so it makes sense that in our
ancestors if you broke your jaw you
couldn't have your jaw wired shut and
feed through a tube that would just
possibly be catastrophic right I mean
life life ending
um and so it makes sense that selection
would favor a bit more robust
um skulls that said uh there has been a
sort of reduction in
overall skull robusticity and the over
the past few million years and I wonder
how much of that has to do with um
changes in our Weaponry going more
toward
um cutting and puncturing
um yeah a big thing brow makes very
little difference
to yeah to hominins you know
five six million years ago when they
were only bashing
um
and there and there was huge sexual
dimorphism in the shape of the skull as
well back then so when it comes to
talking about this male male aggression
that we're discussing here
how does that help men get mates surely
there's still the female that is an
element of this I understand how it
helps you win a fight but it it's not
necessarily apparent how it would make
you better at getting a mate yeah that's
something that I've I've wondered about
a lot because you know for one thing
we're not a species like elephant seals
where
um males fight for a piece of real
estate on a breeding Beach they exclude
all their males and then
um the the beach Master the dominant
male has exclusive sexual access to
um all the females in the spot of real
estate that he's been able to to defend
we're not like that we live in
multi-male multi-female groups and um
and there's almost certainly been lots
of scope from mate choice and so you
know how does dominance competition
translate and and to mating
opportunities and there are a few ways
one of them is coalitional aggression
which is something so I mentioned that
like in small-scale societies you
probably you know people who study this
would still call it Warfare
um this happens in in our closest living
relative chimpanzees as well that groups
of males will attack other groups or
especially single individuals from other
groups
um and um and uh take females from those
groups and that's something that seems
to you know in the historical records
and there's even archaeological evidence
um that that's something that has
happened in human groups over time that
sort of males attacking other groups
killing some enemies and abducting
um females
um so that's one way that male male
aggression could result in mating
opportunities
um there's within groups
um
fights over you know when two males are
after the same female
um you know Frank Marlow was an
anthropologist who studied the hadza
they were one of the last
hunter-gatherer groups in in the world
um and um only about a thousand of them
left and he talked about
um how in the Hudson's freemate Choice
unless two guys are interested in the
same woman and then one might kill the
other one with an arrow which kind of
constrains the scope for for mate Choice
um but that's something that happens and
you know male aggression often occurs
when two when male aggression happens it
often occurs when two guys are
interested in the same female
um and also defensive Mates is another
way
um and Napoleon shagnon was an
anthropologist who studied the the Yana
mama who are horticulturists from um
South America and he talked about how
when one male suspects another one of
tristing with his wife then he can sort
of challenge him to a fight
um and that sometimes results in death
as well but they're sort of you know a
way of fighting translating into
retaining a mate but then really I think
the threat of all these things you know
that like like I mentioned that human
males are not unabatedly at one
another's throats fighting all the time
but there's the sort of potential for it
and that the threats of those things
um Can deter Rivals from trying to win
the same mate that a male is going to
try to get or to uh to you know cheat
with another guy's wife or mate or
something like that so
um but then also it's the case that
across species when males compete
through contest competition
females often evolve preferences for
dominant males
or males of high status and the traits
that win status because when you think
about it it's for females if they just
let males duke it out males are imposing
strong selection on one another to see
who's the fittest or whatever and so
females can sort of then just sit back
and say oh well that guy must be
successful so that happens in in many
species and it could be the case too
that you know uh social status is highly
attractive and you can sort of let males
decide who's whose High status among
themselves and then pick that you know
the winners I had a conversation with
Rob Henderson uh last week and he taught
me about this study that had been done
where uh men and women
reported uh based on the faces of the
people that they saw the relative
attractiveness and dominance uh so the
men judge the dominance and the women
judge the attractiveness and they found
that over the next year all of the men
whose photos they used then self-report
to the number of sexual partners that
they'd had and the men that were judging
the dominance were more accurate at rank
ordering the faces
based on how many sexual partners they
would have dominance was a better
predictor of sexual partners than
attractiveness from women so it seems
like the men were better able to predict
the number of sexual partners that the
men would have than the women were
despite the fact that women are the
market for what these men were going for
that is an awesome study and at first I
wanted I wanted to know is this a study
that he did because it also it sounds
like one that okay I think it's one that
I did it very well might be your
studying I think I think you're
describing a paper that we published in
evolution and human behavior a few years
ago where we had
um
we wanted to study this phenomenon
and to try to understand
um whether
um success in male male competition was
a better predictor of mating success
than success under female choice and so
we said look
um what this would have looked like over
most of human evolution was probably not
a whole bunch of strangers raiding
strangers faces and voices and whatever
it'd be like people mostly knowing each
other and
um so why don't we get a bunch of guys
who know each other to assess the
prestige and dominance and so on of guys
that they know and then have women who
know the guys
based on everything their sense of humor
their intelligence how nice they are but
also whatever that you know how good
looking how dominant what
um how attractive they are and then
um
use
that information to predict guys number
of sexual partners and what we found was
that um oh and what what do we how do we
do this we recruited um two of the
largest social fraternities
um at Penn State and then they're
socially Affiliated sororities
um to participate in the study and and
we found that guys
were able to that their their sort of
average rankings of guys dominance um
predicted guys number of sex partners
um and when we put those in a
statistical model with
how attractive the women who knew the
guys said the guys were that that though
attractiveness ratings didn't explain
any additional variation in number of
sex partners you're kidding me Beyond
dominance and you know it's funny I just
lectured on that um and I took it out of
my lecture
um this year because I'm behind on
things and I thought oh it's you know
it's one study in the in American
undergrads and you know I can cut it out
um but I often you know when I do in
past semesters when I talk about that
particular study I sort of presented to
the classes like uh how does this happen
because doesn't it feel like what's
really determining uh
a guy is sort of mating success is
whether women find him attractive I mean
doesn't that really have don't you have
that strong feeling in this Society
that's the primary determinant and I'm
not sure exactly but it could be things
like you know in um
uh bars and parties and wherever the
sort of mating relationships are formed
that dominant males
um are not challenged if they're trying
to attract a female subordinate males or
got you know guys who are clearly
wimpier would never
impose themselves and and inject
themselves into that conversation and
say oh no talk to me
um whereas a dominant male would have no
compunction about you know
um getting in the middle of this wimpy
guy is talking to this really good
looking woman and have no problem just
you know yeah out of the way and and so
I I don't know that's one possibility
but
um I'd love to study sort of the
the actual causal connection there yeah
I would also be very interested to find
out how online dating uh in the modern
world is changing this right you know
how easy is it to show dominance I'll
press these really uh over a Tinder
profile or an Instagram account uh you
know what what cues is a high follow
account and a blue tick what did they
give off does that show Prestige does it
show dominance is there a way that you
could construct a bunch of fake
Instagram accounts and the kind of
photos that were being taken and the
kind of language that was being used and
the follow account uh is there a way
that you would be able to work that out
because you know the environment now of
whatever you're talking about here like
almost mate guarding in a way or a
potential mate guarding when you're
chatting somebody up in a party that
that's doesn't work anymore anybody can
message anybody on Tinder that's right
yeah it and my my guess is if you did a
study like that I mean
just based on the the sort of
research that's already been done I just
don't think that very dominant appearing
guys are going to be attractive I mean I
just think that you know women tend to
prefer sort of somewhere close to the
male average for traits you know like a
little taller than average but not too
tall a little more muscular than average
but not too muscular the faces that
manipulate facial masculinity some find
that on average women preferred a little
bit to the feminine side of male average
some a little bit more masculine but
surround the average same with voice
pitch it's like too low is kind of weird
sounding but um but so a little lower
than average probably
um but I I really think that yeah if you
made a guy seem very dominant he would
seem I don't know a scary anti-social
something and you know yeah think about
it this way think about the fact that
your study was able to look at what
women said that they wanted
that was what that was the stated
preference right of this person we heard
them right on sort of how attractive a
guy would be for a long-term committed
relationship
um and also for just sex and but if if
the men if the dominance element is
somehow influenced by the presence of
other men and then you take those men
out of the equation in online dating
right what are you left with well I
wonder whether the uh subjective ratings
of attractiveness from women are now
less encumbered somehow whether or not
they're able to uh take less heed of
other men's cues of this guy's dominant
or not dominant I think you're right I
think that's I think that's what you
would see and so my suspicion is that
these the the sort of dominant traits
and dominant behavior
um is functional in a setting where
there are male competitors and that you
know it for sure
um
when women have been asked to rate
Behavior like videos of males they're
they might like dominant Behavior
directed toward other males but they
certainly don't like dominant Behavior
directed towards females so
um
yeah
okay so what about the difference in
male and female mental capabilities
we've spoken just there about the
ability to throw I know that on average
how much trouble are you trying to get
me inside I know
maybe we've already talked about
transports
um but I read something about
um Manda better at spatial rotation and
women are better at remembering
directions or something what is it what
are some of the different capabilities
yeah so
um there are I mean if you
measure overall cognitive function with
like an IQ test there's no difference
male and males and females have the same
average now that's by Design because IQ
tests have similar or composed of
similar numbers of the types of
questions that women tend to do better
at or females tend to do better at and
some and and other ones that males tend
to do better at
um most cognitive
traits don't show a very big sex
difference the biggest ones are in
spatial cognition and they're not huge
but about one standard deviation sex
difference or the biggest ones and
um on average males do better at mental
rotation so if you're shown the sort of
most sort of gold standard test or the
most common test is
um to take to be shown a two-dimensional
picture of a three-dimensional block
figure it just looks kind of like you
know something like that like one of
those um
three by three by three cubes that you
have you take apart and have to put
together again like looks exactly like
one of those pieces
um and then you ask which of these which
two of these fourth other images are is
just that thing rotated in space and um
and if you have a bunch of males and
females do this
um then you get about uh 0.6 to 1.0
standard deviation male Advantage you
get a bigger male Advantage when you
make the test harder
um so if you give them less time to do
it for example if you give if you give
people all the time that they need then
eventually most people can can do it
um and then there's a female Advantage
at object location memory
um and one
one test that's been that's been uh
published is the memory game you know
with the cards you flip over you have a
bunch of cards face down and then you
flip them over in pairs and I can
remember doing that before I knew about
a sex difference like that I remember
doing that with my with my girlfriend in
college and
um it's like sweating bullets and she
was destroying me and I was trying so
hard to to concentrate and she seemed to
do it effortlessly and then later you
know I found out that there's a pretty
good size sex difference in
um a female advantage and I was like ah
okay maybe that's you should have you
should have told it to come to the pub
and play Dots so that you could open it
up yeah right
um but anyway
um
so those are the biggest sex differences
in spatial cognition and
um
also if you there's a test that is that
rodents are put into called a Morris
water maze it's a a pool of water filled
with some opaque
um substance like powdered milk so that
you can't see and there's a underneath
the surface and there's a little
platform just underneath the surface so
if you put rats in this thing just put
them in the Maze it's a you know I don't
know how big a 10 feet across or
something like that and you put them in
um then they would like to not be
swimming they'd like to find the
platform and climb up on it and stand on
it um and so what you can do is measure
and put them in different places in the
Maze each time and you can see like how
how quickly they learn the location of
that platform under the water that they
can't see oh they get create a abstract
map of what it actually is like yeah
yeah and
um and so you know there's a sex
difference in that
um that males tend to learn it faster
they they tend to find that platform and
so the latency between when you put them
in the pool and when they get onto the
platform
and it isn't to do with swimming ability
or motivation or something you know
those things have been tested
um
but if you mess with the cues like the
landmarks within the maze right inside
of you know sort of marks on the on the
border of the maze itself that messes up
females more
and if you mess up if you if you
manipulate extra maze cues like things
that are better for gauging distance and
Direction that's that messes up males
more so it suggests that they're using
sort of different information to
navigate and it's testosterone dependent
if you treat females with early in life
with antigen they solve the maze like a
male and if you castrate males they
solve it like a female and this
difference seems to characterize species
where males have a bigger home range
that they have to travel over a larger
area to locate females because you know
both sexes are about the same size and
they have a range that they they range
over the same geographic area just to
get food but then if males are also
collagenous and trying to mate with
multiple females then they range over a
bigger area then they need
sort of different spatial cognitive
abilities including ones that rely Less
on local landmarks and more on direction
and distance
um and so
anyway the the sex differences that we
see probably existed like you know
ancestrally in mammals a long time ago
but then
um were subsequently shaped by other
things like
um possibly male you know targeting
different foraging strategies more male
hunting
um ranging over a broader distance to to
track prey and and Hunt versus foraging
which is closer to home
um what does the and also targeting yeah
what does the ability to remember cards
like ancestrally what is that related to
yeah the idea is that
um it's related to remembering where
food resources that are stationary in
the environment are located and that's
kind of a stretch
um but there was a cool study by um
Steve gone was the senior author um at
UC Santa Barbara that had
recruited participants in a farm farmers
market and um and had participants at
the end after they'd spent time in the
market come back and say okay Point me
in the direction of the honey point me
in the direction of the lettuce or
whatever and what they found was a
female advantage and that
um the higher the caloric Returns the
bigger the sex difference I think it was
um so you know it's like the the attempt
there was to be more ecological to say
to show a sex difference in object
location memory
that was more like foraging you know
remembering the location of food in the
environment
um pretty cool study
um so that's that's the reasoning but it
could also just be that if you're
ranging over a smaller area you don't
have to travel over such as a large area
to get animals or to find mates
um then you a different sort of
navigational strategy makes more sense
um using landmarks I'm going to say
something incredibly sexist here
um I wonder whether this plays into the
women are able to uh be more organized
and tidy when it comes to a smaller area
like a house and men are better at when
it comes to longer uh greater distance
organization like driving like I know
it's a total meme right to talk about
how men yeah how men men are better at
being able to remember locations and and
to be able to get directions and stuff
like that but I do wonder whether this
would map across and I have tons of male
friends that are absolutely useless
behind the wheel so I I mean I'm an N of
one here right let me ask for directions
all the time yeah precisely but yeah I
do wonder if you would be able to look
at
um it would suggest to me that women
would be better able to organize stuff
within a smaller location that's what
we're talking about right
um
uh what does this mean that men more
often lose their keys than women do does
this mean that uh women more often take
the wrong route to some place without
using satellite navigation than men do
like that would be interesting I I don't
know about organizing a like a domicile
um but
I have often in my life attributed that
sort of Supernatural ability to remember
where the cues are
I mean I've got you know a wife two
daughters and a son and actually my
son's pretty good remember this stuff
but generally I the females know where
things are uh you know
it might be related to this and and you
know there's another study that show
that has participants
um look at an array of common objects
you know teddy bear a telephone a
barbell you know whatever just some
common things that you might see
and then um
they're shown that same array of you
know array of objects again and asked
which of these things have been moved or
removed and again there's a big sex
difference favoring females it seems to
be a bigger sex difference maybe it only
occurs when participants are given a
distractor task in other words you're
told to be doing something else and
thinking about something else other than
memorizing where all these things are
and then you and then you you test them
on their remote on their memory and find
that women were remembering where those
things were better even when they were
focusing on doing something totally
different
um and I mean it Accords with my
experience
um but yeah I would never want to use um
my sort of anecdotes as as that's the
new stuff Bro Science stated we don't
need to do real science we've got bro
signs okay so you you've done all of
this work as well about
um vocal pitch and and what what the
voice pitch uh can do did you do a study
that looked at you can tell someone's
personality from their voice yeah I was
a a co-author I can't claim credit for
that I provided some data and helped
with um the writing a bit
um but it was really a study out of Lars
pinque's lab he's at University of
goettingen in Germany and um and one of
the results that stuck out to me was
that there was a relationship
um between the sort of dominance
characteristic of personality and and
voice but
um
yeah I can't really claim
claim credit for that study um but it's
cool and it looks like it's been it's
being you know cited pretty highly too
so that's kind of a nice thing
um we've definitely looked at
this idea in our lab this has been one
is sort of
interesting questions driving our recent
research is
um why we would pay attention to voice
pitch and other characteristics of the
voice like vocal Timber which also shows
a big sex difference uh males have a uh
our larynx descends a full vertebra
lower at puberty in the vocal track so
that our vocal track sounds longer than
it is I mentioned that males are about
seven to eight percent taller so their
Vocal Track should be about seven or
eight percent longer but it's 15 longer
so twice that
um because of this Descent of the larynx
at puberty so really we have these
exaggerations of size like males voices
look like they've evolved to make males
seem big and scary and so then we've
asked yeah but if that's the case then
why do we pay attention if it's just
kind of um
you know a deceptive signal to say look
at how big I am why do we why why is
selection favored continued
attentiveness to this why do we continue
to defer resources mates whatever to
males because we should we should have
discounted for the fact that it's
already small yeah yeah yeah if it
doesn't advertise anything so that's
been something we've looked at with
personality but also things like
um you know body size well there's a
weak relationship but it's not not not a
strong one but you know larger males
have lower pitch and Timber
testosterone seems to be a bit stronger
relationship there and especially if you
look at cortisol which is a stress
hormone so guys who have both
um low cortisol low stress hormone and
high testosterone have especially deep
voices and that's a kind of a stronger
relationship it's not
super strong but it's you know it's it's
there and it's one of the stronger ones
um we've looked at like fighting ability
so we looked at MMA fighters to see if
their voice pitch predicted their you
know success in in fighting and that
sort of thing a little bit of evidence
that basically bigger MMA fighters and
ones who have more fighting experience
had lower pitch voices and
um but that's been a really interesting
question about sort of
um why do we continue to defer to this
trait you know does it actually
advertise is there a kernel of Truth
does it advertise something relevant
about the sort of competitiveness of
another male that's really really
interesting I wonder how much of the low
advice is because they've been punched
and choked out a lot I wonder whether
you can uh just if you also you get if
you get someone in a rear naked choke
enough that I don't know hyper Trophies
the the vocal cords somehow well then
you'd have a relationship in the
opposite direction that um you know a
low voice lower voice less success than
if you've been choked out too many times
yeah that's a good sounding like we have
two effects yeah
um so and you know it's not it's not
really
um when we first started doing this
um
I thought
uh the guy who proposed the study I
thought that is the coolest study
because you know we're never going to
get data like this in the lab you can't
get a bunch of guys to come in and fight
each other and then you you measure
their voice and see whether
um
you know voice pitch predicts fighting
success and so I thought that is a
really cool way of sort of looking at
natural variation and fighting ability
but the reality is that
MMA fighters are not typical right
they're like the
best fighters and as MMA is that I don't
I don't know I don't remember all the
details about you know you can do this
kind of fighting but then the ones that
we measure like the professional
fighters who so they're like you know
the top fraction of a percent or
something like that so there's some
issue there with like there's really low
variation in fighting ability basically
well also I imagine that there are a lot
of different ways to win a fight
especially when it comes to MMA it's not
simply the most dominant man that goes
in there it can be selected for all
sorts of things conscientiousness uh
industriousness like openness to be able
to try new things it's like a a huge
number of different ways that you could
ever you see this in fighting right
everybody knows oh that's the tactician
the person that sits back a little bit
more or that's the guy that's the
brawler he's the sort of all-out
testosterone guy and what you've
actually seen if you were to track
something like UFC over the last 30
years since it started you've moved more
away from the Chuck Liddell Anthony
Rumble Johnson's style of just a
straighter brawler to now someone who is
much more of a
a Hitman somebody that's incredibly
technical with their skill okay well
what is that what's that selecting for I
mean there'll be some dominance in there
there'll be a good bit of testosterone
in there but it's it's less about the
all-out war and it's more about this
sort of very precise selection of roots
to success that's really interesting
yeah when we we approaching we're just
you know sort of coming from the
question of
if you do rating studies if you say
manipulate voice pitch to make make male
voices the same male voices seem lower
or higher than the perceptual effect you
get is that if you make a voice lower
the guy sounds like a better fighter and
so then we and if you look at sort of
correlational just don't manipulate
anything and just have people rate guys
voices you find that voice pitch
predicts lower voices are rated as as
better Fighters so we've sort of
approach it from that perspective of
regardless of how they become a good
fighter whether it's from punching or
wrestling or choking out or whatever but
just if
um they have a lower voice pitch are
they a better fighter in other words is
it you know useful to pay attention to
this trait of voice pitch and sort of
assessing the formidability of the
competitor and
yeah I mean
we found some evidence in MMA fighters
professional MMA fighters my assist
mission is that there would be a
stronger relationship if you just took a
random sample of guys especially because
there's probably a bigger variation in
everything that you're interested in
including fighting ability
um but size and things like that too so
yeah you mentioned the story about when
you were in the shopping center and the
two guys were competing for who could
have the lower voice pitch have you
actually done any studies on whether or
not men and women modulate their voice
pitch based on areas of high mating
competition that they're in yes
um
one only one that I can think of right
now and it was actually part of the
dissertation research where
um
I had guys come into the lab they were
told that they were gonna
um be in a sort of a dating game thing
and they could win a lunch date with a
with a woman
she was a friend who I did a video she
it turned out to be a good actress and
she was the potential date and she was
on a webcam you know but it was actually
recorded So everybody saw the same
female she was supposedly in the Next
Room and there was another guy in a
third room a competitor and um before
any of this I had the guys come in and I
recorded I think it was a hundred
uh how many times was it 100
something 111 maybe 111 guys one at a
time
um they came into the lab and I recorded
their voice before they knew anything
about this circumstances and then I
recorded their voice when they were
talking to their competitor and you
might think that as soon as they started
talking to the competitor they you know
tried to sound all deep and masculine
but the reality was that some guys
lowered their pitch when talking to the
competitor and other guys raised their
pitch when they were talking to their
competitor and we could predict whether
a guy lowered or raised his pitch based
on whether he rated himself
the participant rated himself the
speaker rated himself as a better
fighter than he rated his competitor
which was the same guy that everybody
heard he was also a friend of mine who
was recorded and so it was the same
across all participants but if guys
perceive themselves as less good
Fighters than their competitor they
tended to raise their pitch from
Baseline when they spoke to him and if
they perceive themselves as better uh
Fighters and they lowered their pitch
which makes sense because you'd expect
that you know if a voice pitch doesn't
just sort of influence dominance
relationships but the dominance
relationships would also influence how
we modulate our voices across contexts
and so
um and we you know we did another study
um
a few years after that showing that
um the same people when they were asked
to speak on a topic that they were an
expert on tended to speak in a lower
pitch than if they were not an expert on
the topic so you know lowering pitch
seems like it's a sort of uh you're
signaling status Authority
dominance if that's relevant and
probably in male undergraduates it was
very relevant you know much more than
you know older people yeah okay it's a
key of confidence as well that I know
what I'm doing here I feel comfortable
in this situation and the reverse is
that it's subservience it's I I am no
threat you don't need to worry about me
listen to me in my higher pitched voice
I'm absolutely no concern to you please
don't punch me in the face that yeah
that's exactly right and you know all
species where that have this sort of you
know fighting for whatever resources or
mates or whatever it it pays to evolve
um signals of deference as well because
um you know it would not benefit
everybody to advertise their maximum
dominance to every competitor because
that just invites you know an escalation
of of competition and um if if you're
pretty confident that you're not going
to win then you would like to back out
and say no I'm not signaling
um you know aggression here I'm I'm
signaling that you know you win and
let's not fight you know so it makes
sense I mean it would not it would not
have paid our ancestors too
um
evolve
signaling threat potential all the time
well especially given what we spoke
about at the start which was
men specifically are trying to do
everything that they can to Signal
dominance and aggression without having
to actually get into the act of being
aggressive
right yeah yeah and in certain contexts
not others you know not
um
I mean
plenty people do people modulate their
voice across context all the time right
I mean if I'm you know
back when you couldn't tell who was
calling you you're talking and then my
wife or you know calls it oh hi honey
you know your voice goes up or to kids
you know you talk to kids in a in a
non-threatening voice like uh you know
so
um yeah anyway
um I think voice has probably been a
really
I I went into studying it
um with no special interest in voice but
just thinking this will be a really
useful model trait for us trying to
understand human mating competition and
it's it's you know it's really paid off
um as a traitly imminently quantifiable
you know it's unlike face faces which
are hard to measure you know it's really
easy to measure it there's a huge sex
difference of about
five standard deviations or more in
voice pitch that occurs at puberty when
when meeting competition becomes more
intense and um and uh you know it seems
to be related to mate preferences and
and
dominance competition including how we
modulate it so
um yeah anyway all right David let's
bring this one home what are you working
on next what's is there anything cool
that you've got that you you're doing
right now uh yeah we're well we're
working on some studies that we didn't
really get too much into those topics
but
um looking at sort of how sex hormones
um influence our our psychology and
behavior so we have one study where
we're looking at
um people who have a condition where
they had low sex hormones males and
females both have this condition
um called ihh where they had low sex
hormone levels from the second trimester
of gestation all the way to puberty when
they get on hormone replacement therapy
and so we can look at how um having low
sex hormones low estrogens and
progestogens if you're female or low
androgens like testosterone if you're
male how that influences psychology and
behavior we're doing another study
looking at um women's phenotypes there's
psychology behavior and other and voice
over the ovulatory cycle with changes in
sex hormones
um and then we've got a couple of papers
looking at uh voice across cultural
voice study looking at how voice
pitch influences perceptions of
attractiveness and dominance across
societies and what socio-cultural
variables modulate those influences and
another study that's across species
comparison looking at
when you see the evolution of big sex
differences in voice pitch across
primates and how it seems to be related
to
um male male competition group size
things like that a bunch of other things
but those are some of the I think most
exciting ones we're doing right now
that's cool why should people go if they
want to keep up to date with those
studies and the stuff that you're
working on
um well if if it's published studies
Google Scholar is always a great place
to go um you can just search for you
know an author's um Google Scholar
account and you'll see everything that's
published recently
um some studies we might talk about on
my lab website at Penn State but most of
the time we we don't really say much
about a study until we're we've
published it so yeah all right David I
appreciate you thank you
thanks Chris good talking to you what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
face
[Music]